Super Mario Brothers okay let's get it
the reason why the Rotten Tomato scores
is what it is and pardon my voice I'm
underweather
Disney is bombarding them right they
trying to keep those uh the ratings low
so dudes would be like nah I ain't gonna
go see that it already surpassed their
greatest movie so far and it's on its
way it could be frozen it'd be frozen
too Frozen one I mean Frozen two beat
Frozen one
um
and that was domestically so this is a
sh I'm trying to watch it Tuesday
yeah no we win we're not gonna spoil
anything okay I'm just gonna say you're
in for the greatest treat as a fan and
if you were there from the 80s yeah man
everything yes everything everything
I mean the new ones just look all the
way yeah everything everything listen
for listen for everything look at
everything it is it is fan service to
the max